Samsung unveiled its new smartphone the
Galaxy Note bakes at a ceremony
yesterday in New York the company's top
US executive is speaking out for the
first time since last year's botched
rollout of the previous model
dozens of people reported Samsung Note
7's overheated melted or exploded
prompting airline bans and a massive
recall the CEO of Samsung North America
Tim Baxter spoke only to CBS this
morning and assured us the problem has
been fixed so this is a maybe hopefully
for you a phoenix from the ashes story
no pun intended
take me back if you would lessons learn
what it was like getting the call and
realizing the problem you had I would
say I am without a doubt bill it was the
most difficult 120 days of my career you
were dealing with a very fluid
environment you were dealing with safety
concerns and as an organization we
really pulled together and really guided
ourselves around one simple thing what's
in the best interests of the consumer
and consumer safety what was the problem
why were these phones igniting it was
really two things Vil 1e was and it was
both related to the battery one was a
supply from one of our suppliers the
design of it did not properly get
executed and the second one was actually
in the process of ramping up their
production and they had some
manufacturing issues so those two
sequential things created this double
recall or expanded recall that we that
we had to manage through well things
were melting down you appeared in a
video to be clear the note 7 with the
new battery is safe the battery cell
issue is resolved and then those turned
out to be a problem what did that do to
your credibility now it was it was a it
was a difficult experience and I think
the important piece though was to really
reach out and be able to talk directly
to the consumers and Samsung owned that
we apology
and we're continuing to learn from that
and rebuild trust but the most
interesting part about this is I've had
Town Hall's I've talked to dozens and
dozens of consumers we've held video
chats to ten thousand people the first
question I always get bill is when can I
get the know date the answer soon the
Galaxy Note 8 after the company unveiled
its new phone yesterday
features include live messaging so you
and I can take a selfie okay right there
we go all right
hi gal and Nora Oh perfect right it
animates messages as gift files that can
play on any phones I'm gonna launch my
camera samsung also touts the phone's
dual cameras which allow users to soften
the backgrounds of their photos and the
6.3 inch screen can accommodate multiple
programs running side-by-side gives me
the calendar it gives me the phone
I can just make a call and I can
continue to multitask I can look at this
guy here it is it looks like is that an
iPhone
maxtor admits the competitive
environment is intense are you doing
good thanks that's your chance you
convince him he's got the wrong phone I
should have listened
Apple is expected to announce a new
version of the iPhone next month and
Baxter says both companies will be
targeting the more than 50 million
Americans who become eligible for phone
upgrades this fall we're giving
consumers choices and they're gonna have
the opportunity to get the best from
both brands and and that's pretty
exciting
Samsung expresses confidence that its
battery problems are in the past after
last year's debacle that added a new
eight point battery safety check with
various tests visual inspections and
x-rays and while this is the first note
phone to come out since then the company
did will allow new versions of its
Galaxy S line in the spring helping
Samsung regain the top spot in the
global smartphone market
is there any hint of a lump in your
chest as the eight goes out it shifts
out around the world hoping that history
doesn't repeat here you know we learned
a lot as we went through we implemented
a number of new processes not only the
eight point battery but we established a
forensic lab in Dallas so we can get on
top of any issues that that occurred any
of those lumps went away with the launch
of the Galaxy s8 where we have shipped
over 20 million devices without an
incident and will build upon that
platform with the no date so I feel much
better
coming into this launch Samsung is
taking presale orders starting today
starts around 930 bucks
the company says it won't be available
until middle of next month and previous
owners of the note 7 you get a discount
trading in your current that Kobe says
the company owned it and Samsung sells
more phones than iPhone in the world
with iPhone that feature is very cool